do not drink the airplane bathroom water
- people tend to join the mile-high club
yes it is a big fantasy for everyone
everyone tries to give you a little tip
money pretty sure I had passengers give
each other hand jobs right in front of
me so what did I do well offer him a
warm towel if you get caught doing it is
a big deal it's a federal offense you
get arrested and you will be fined you
will be banned from the airline and no
more flying for you to Mexico
deciding to talk about passenger yes all
the time oh my gosh that's the first
thing out of our mouth we always know
what's going on with our passengers from
the moment they step on that plane there
should be a greeter up at the front
saying welcome aboard and at that moment
we know if we've got a you know newlywed
couple going on their honeymoon or
somebody who's a first-time flyer you
says I'm nervous I'm a first-time flyer
most of the time they'll tell us or
they'll give us some type of cue first
of all when you're boarding we're always
checking you out seeing who's the sexy
one and then we're eight like okay who's
the hottest guy in coach or girl who's
the hottest guy or girl in first class
and then who's the hottest person in the
whole plane so if you see us on the back
talking and giggling and looking at the
passengers that's most likely because
I'm talking about you
what is potable water how is it used on
a plane it's the water we use for the
lavatory and for the coffee
the theme water I'll leave that up to
you if you want to drink your coffee I
wouldn't drink the coffee on the plane
they don't clean the the tubes where the
water goes so you're drinking all of
that so if you want water get it from
the bottled water what is the dirtiest
part of an airplane
definitely the floor before get too used
and abused if people are walking all
around that floor bringing stuff in
taking stuff off dropping things
not like a bare foot on that airplane
especially going into the lavatory
everyone's always walking around
barefoot and getting like fungus or
something I've seen people walk getting
barefoot in the lavatory
like oh that's a lot of confidence bring
your own Clorox wipe no guarantee if
those tray tables or seats get cleaned
after every flight in between flights
they do clean but what they mean by
cleaning is they vacuum the carpet and
they do wipe down the lavatories but
every single trade table no they don't
wipe that down they only do that only if
the plane is like sitting in the airport
for like overnight or something
how can a passenger get into first-class
well they can buy ticket upgrade your
life you're gonna work harder you gotta
buy a ticket man there's just no way or
they can ask a flight attendant never
hurts to ask if they can talk their way
into it some of them and they ask nicely
they can get into first class I've seen
it done before we're not supposed to but
if you're really cute we just say hey
come over I'd rather have you over here
if you guys are gonna be asking you ask
before the plane takes off if you want
to get anything free on an airplane it's
actually pretty easy just to be super
nice to your flight attendants ever you
having a good drink or two I've met a
lot of flight attendants that would just
be like I'll come back and charge you
later and they never come back our diet
drinks the worst drinks to order on a
flight diet cola
is literally the worst drink to pour on
a flight the bubbles for some reason
they never go down they're so busy so
we'll open the can and pour it and we'll
literally just wait that fizz take so
long to defibs that I could pour it of
whole plane drinks by the time that Diet
Coke Dee fizzes if you order a diet coke
with me you'll probably get the whole
can because I don't got time for all
that well thanks for watching hopefully
you learned some important helpful tips
for your next flight be a nice to your
flight attendant and bye bye have a good
day goodbye so be nice to your flight
attendants just like you would be nice
to your waitresses and puppy dog or just
start for your safety dang it